my outfit
tonight ja first of all it was a game of
runs early in this game basketball is
but what was it that allowed you guys to
get away from him there in the second
half uh just being resilient obviously
we know we had to correct uh we played
very well early on got to uh you know a
good lead obviously like you said
basketball the game of runs it's a
talented team who can score the ball
very well they got back in it which we
knew but we just had to stay together
and go back to you know being
disciplined playing our ball and we was
able come out with a win best offensive
team in the league you went up against
tonight you hold him to 103 what what
worked defensively uh was just trying to
make their shots as tough as possible
obviously the head of the snake you know
with Hal bur we just try to make you
know his shots tougher and he's just so
willing to get off the ball it makes it
tough to guard uh we just try to get out
contest shots and then rebound I imagine
it was another emotional day for you
your first time back in this building
this season what was it like for you
today and when you were announced
tonight the crowd went there was
electric for you uh it was good it was
good I loved it obviously like I said
this my family here I love to be able to
you know play in front of them again and
definitely love to you know come and get
a win but
uh yeah man I I just love it don't make
me get emotional right here in front of
the camera man y welcome back
congratulations on the game and uh see
you in Atlanta yes sir it's a
p you ain't got it today we ain't ready
yet we ain't ready
yet I'll say it's a parade inside my
city
yeah